SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: It's a pleasure
to get the chance to talk,
particularly [AUDIO OUT] because
I think this, in some ways,
is the first big punch
line of the term, something
that-- material you've
been hearing about
has been leading up to.
I guess it depends on
whether you consider yourself
an engineer or a theoretician.
If you're a
theoretician, this is
going to seem kind
of pretty simplistic.
If you're a practitioner,
an engineer,
you're going to say this is--
I hope you'll say this is
what we've been waiting for.
And what it is really how
we take a lot of the stuff
that you've been learning
about physical processes
and the reasons they go
bad and some basic theory
on statistics, particularly
normal statistics,
and actually put it
into some sort of use.
And we'll do this--
this is really sort of SPC in--
I was going to say 90 minutes,
but in less than 90 minutes.
And if you follow everything
that's in today's lecture
and follow what's in the book,
you kind of have it all, OK?
And then it's just
a matter of a lot
of shades of gray around that.
Making it more applicable,
and understanding
some of the subtleties.
The other part of it,
if I don't get too wordy
and we don't have any
technical problems,
is process capability.
And process
capability in my mind
is the meeting of the two
great forces in manufacturing
or in a manufacturing company.
And that's the relationship--
those are the organizations
of design and manufacturing.
And it really is just where
the two are brought together.
And it's ultimately very simple.
It has a lot of implications,
but it's ultimately
a very simple concept.
And both of these things are
things that historically you
might say were discovered
or put together and learned
in the United States.
They were unlearned-- it's
an interesting history
on this-- completely
unlearned and transferred
to other countries,
in particular Japan,
and then relearn
back in this country.
So there's some
interesting history.
If you read about Shewhart, if
you read about Edwards Deming,
and you read about Juran,
these are the people
that kind of invented
and then brought it back
to this country.
And it's now-- you know,
again, I find myself now having
worked in this area long enough
to tell stories that you have
to understand that your
background, this has probably
been in your entire
adult life, this has just
been standard
practice in industry
pretty much around the world.
But I can tell
you, 15 years ago,
which for me wasn't--
which, for me, is yesterday,
this stuff was still
kind of being discovered.
But now, at least, it maybe
isn't dogma yet everywhere,
but it's pretty close to that.
OK.
So enough of my soapbox.
There's an
interesting paper that
was written by
Shewhart back when
he was with Bell Laboratories.
Bell Laboratories used to be
the premier industrial research
laboratory in the United
States, maybe in the world.
And of course, did a lot of work
on communications and telephony
and things like that
and a lot of things
on basic information--
on, of course,
on the hardware of that.
Software didn't really
exist back then,
but the hardware of it and
other things was done there.
And they had a large
theoretical group.
And Shewhart, as I understand,
was a statistician.
And Bell Labs also,
in their connection
with Western Electric--
Western Electric was
the manufacturing arm
of the Bell System,
which was the one
big monopoly in the United
States at that time.
So they owned the
phone system, and they
manufactured all the phones.
That was an interesting
era in history, too.
You could get your
phones from anybody
as long as it was
Western Electric.
And you could get any color you
wanted as long as it was black.
They made very solid phones, but
there wasn't a lot of variety.
But they always worked.
Anyway, they did a lot
of work on improving
telephony and other
things like that,
and a lot of statistics
and mathematics
got developed around
control systems.
Those if you who've taken
control courses, I think--
I'm trying to think, well, I
might get some of these names
wrong, but some of the
techniques and other things
that are there came
from the concept
of developing better
amplifiers for undersea
cables and other things
like that for telephony.
At the same time this
development of statistics
and applied statistics was
being used in that area,
this guy Shewhart comes along
and says, wait a second.
We have this manufacturing.
And what this little
quote here, which
is the introduction
to this one paper--
he wrote a series of papers.
It basically says is that--
he's stating what maybe is
the obvious back in, I think,
1925, which is the
objective of manufacturing
typically is to
create a products that
are as uniform as possible.
And you can set up
all the conditions
you want around the
production to make things
as uniform as possible,
which is exactly what we've
been talking about.
Control your inputs.
Control your process
variables, things like that.
But there will still
be variation in it.
He's basically
saying, if you ever
make things in any
sort of quantity,
you will always see variation.
And he basically
did from that is--
and I don't know
how much of this
came from the idea of quantum
mechanics, which was becoming
popular at that time or was
coming into being well known
by the scientific
community at least, which
is that at some point, once
you reduce things down,
sort of explain everything
that is to be explained,
there's still some inherent
randomness in things.
And so this view of the
idea that there's inherent
randomness in any
physical thing.
Our ability to describe exactly
what's going on eventually
gets limited.
And so that kind of led to this
idea of statistical process
control, which is
really based on the idea
that if I do everything
I can to know everything
I can about a process, then
the only thing that's left
is that unknowable
part, if you will.
The purely random part.
And at one level,
SPC is all about,
first of all,
determining, have I indeed
taken care of all those things
that I should know about
or could know about?
And those are things
that are related
to the physics of the
process that we've
been talking about so far.
And once that's done,
what is the underlying
statistical behavior, random
behavior of the process,
and how well can I
characterize that.
And SPC all gets down to
really basically saying,
have I achieved this
state of pure randomness?
And SPC-- another way of looking
at the Shewhart hypothesis
is, if the process is acting in
any way except purely random,
then you haven't done your job.
Then you can still
improve the process.
OK?
OK.
So I think you can probably
read that on your print out.
I can't read it here.
So, OK.
So the hypothesis in
effect, or the approach,
is to basically
say, all processes
have a certain
degree of randomness.
And this idea of assignable
causes, which are really what--
if you're in a control
systems, from a control systems
background, it would say
disturbances or changes.
If they've all been
eliminated, then it
is a purely random process.
So this concept of
common causes or, again,
purely random effects, if
that's all that's left,
then you do indeed
have a process
that is in a state of
statistical control.
Now, the other
problem here again,
and the reason I
go on about this,
is I came to this whole field--
all my formal education, with
the exception of one or two
classes, never talked
about the concept
of uncertainty or randomness.
And particularly in the
area of control systems,
you think of control as actively
watching something and doing
something about it in
a closed loop fashion.
Statistical process control
is quite different from that.
And the term is used
quite differently.
It really means, have I
eliminated or controlled
everything external
to the process
that could cause it to vary?
And indeed, is it
in a state of what
you'll see in a moment
we'll define as purely
random, stationary behavior.
There's nothing active
about the control at all.
Now, for those of you who have
come up with a control systems
or system dynamics
point of view--
and I think I warned you this is
the last time I talked to you.
I do everything
with block diagrams.
So I have to do this.
We have this
manufacturing process.
And we have certain
inputs to the process.
And these again, are the
things that we can control,
and we should be
able to control.
And we either set them
and leave them alone,
or we control them in a way
that makes the process do
what we want to do.
And that produces
a certain output
through all of the
different materials
and other things like that.
And then in a
control system sense,
there are two reasons that the
relationship between these two
would vary.
And again, the purely
deterministic view of the world
says, look.
If I set some inputs,
I'll get a certain output.
There's a unique mapping between
the inputs and the outputs.
But two things can happen.
You can have things
that are called noise.
And you'll hear that term
throughout the term, actually.
Or disturbances.
And you'll notice that's sort
of external to the-- this
is shown as external
to the process.
And from a mathematical
point of view,
it's shown as being additive.
So imagine that this is a
purely deterministic process.
I hold the input
perfectly constant.
The output stays
perfectly constant,
except that I have a noise
up here that's described,
let's say, by a
normal distribution.
So at any instant in
time, this variable
will be following a
normal distribution.
So the output will follow
And you might say that one
way of looking at the Shewhart
hypothesis is, yeah,
here's this process,
and I've got it
completely under control.
I know everything that's
going on about it.
Nothing inherent in the
process is changing,
but there's this noise
process out here somehow,
and it adds in.
And it's always there.
Now, this turns out to
be a bit of an artifice
because what we all
know is what's really
causing most of
the changes that we
see is a change in the process.
So we have things like a
process noise or disturbance.
And so that means
something inside here,
like those alphas
that we talked about.
The basic parameters
of the process.
The equipment states, the
equipment the parameters.
The material again.
Especially the material changes.
Material is inherent in here.
And so that's going to change.
One of the reasons
we actually do
this out here is that
again, mathematically,
having this change, having
the function change,
becomes really hard to handle.
Additive disturbances
are easy to handle.
Simon.
AUDIENCE: Would you
say that temperature
and material and everything
across [INAUDIBLE]??
What examples do you have
for the noise disturbance?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, good question.
I was going to ask
you the same thing.
You can see that
everything we talked
about when we talked
about the process modeling
had to be here.
OK?
So a couple of things here.
So if the output from
here is a dimension
and you think of the
output of the process
here being a
dimension that results
from the combination of
temperature, pressure, force,
displacement, machine
parameters and all those,
what would ever mess that up?
Measurement.
Yeah.
OK.
So now, we aren't
going to actually talk
a whole lot about
measurement in this class.
But indeed, one of the
good examples of this
is measurement.
So your perceived output is
different from the real output
because of some uncertainty
from the measurement.
So this is also a way of
dealing with measurement noise.
And indeed, we deal
with measurement noise
exactly the same way we
do with processed noise.
So that's why I was saying that
this is a bit of an artifice.
If I assume perfect
measurement, then this
is really a better
model of doing it.
Either way, our
point is going to be
that, and the reason
I put this in here--
let's assume we did the best
job we ever could with this.
In some senses, the Shewhart
hypothesis doesn't matter.
Always going to
have something here.
And he doesn't really try to
explain where it comes from.
That's one of the
differences here.
This is not really physical
origins of variation.
It's just, hey.
Look.
Based on observation,
no matter what you do,
you get some of
this variability.
And your job is to get it
down to the point where
it's, in effect, unexplainable.
OK.
So here's the concept
of being in control.
And this is really
an iconic diagram.
And it tries to illustrate
a number of things.
And I think if you
understand this diagram,
then you really have the essence
of statistical process control.
Now, what you see here are--
again, this is, as the chart
says, going in this way,
you're going in time.
And think of these as
samples or instance of time
or, from a manufacturing
point of view,
it's cycles of the process.
So I make something
at time I, and then
I make something at time
I plus 1 and I plus 2.
Or a better way
to think of it is
I measure what I've made at I.
I measure something else at I
plus 1.
I measure another product at I
plus 1 and I plus 2, and so on.
Each of these, of course, is
representing a probability
distribution.
And they're normal here because
the Shewhart stuff is all
based on assuming the underlying
statistics are normal.
What this is illustrating
is not the data itself
but the distribution of
the data as time moves on.
And what this diagram tells
you is the distribution
is identical.
It doesn't mean we're getting
the same part every time.
It just means the probability of
getting a particular dimension
never changes.
OK?
This is the concept
of statistical--
a state of statistical control.
The underlying
parent distribution,
the true random
behavior of the process,
is following this curve
and never changes.
If you've achieved that, then
by the Shewhart hypothesis,
you're in a state of
statistical control.
And that's essentially
the best you can do.
The best you can do.
And so your process will never
get any better than that.
That's why we have the
second half of the class,
by the way, because what
comes up after this part,
after statistical process
control, we say, OK.
Now, you've got it in the
state of statistical control.
It's following this
distribution for all time.
That's great.
What if that's not
good enough, or what
if it needs to be better?
What if it still has too
much variability compared
to a design specification?
What do you do?
Any ideas on what you do if it's
in perfect state of control,
it's doing exactly
what Shewhart says
it should be doing to be
in a state of control,
and it's not good enough?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] parameters
that narrow the distribution.
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly.
Did you guys hear
that in Singapore?
No?
OK.
AUDIENCE: OK, I heard that.
PROFESSOR: Oh, he heard it.
OK, go ahead.
Oh, you heard it?
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: The research says
about just change, optimize
the parameters of the process.
So try to optimize the process.
So I was going to say
that that is one way.
But the other
methods, for example,
like positive controls, user
feedback control of the system,
and try to improve
the process as well.
So.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
If you go back to that, again,
the somewhat iconic equation
that we had in one of the
first lectures on the variation
equation and the
three things you
can do to reduce
the variation, one
was to eliminate all
these influences, which
is what we're talking
about with SPC.
Another is to try to reduce
the sensitivity of the process
to those inherent
variations, and that's
what Richard was talking
about with changing process
parameters.
And then the third would
be to actually use some--
well, we'll talk about
using feedback control using
some sort of feedback
to improve the process.
There's a fourth one, which
we didn't really put in there.
Well, that's what he
was talking about.
Active control.
Yeah.
Can you generalize that?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah,
Yeah, that's cheating.
Selective assembly?
Ooh.
[LAUGHTER]
None of that.
No, selective assembly--
indeed, selective assembly
is something that you do when
this is the best you can do,
and it's not good enough.
You just take individual
parts and say, will these fit?
Or you gauge-- and
that's was also
my airspace example from
a couple of weeks ago
where you've got the
people behind the curtains
with the padded table
and the padded hammers,
and they're pounding things, and
that sort of custom assembly.
So you can do those
sorts of things.
But the last one
I was thinking of
is you go out and
buy a new process.
OK?
If this is inherent
in the process
and that's the best
that it can do,
then you sort of invent a
new process, if you will,
or you do things a
different way that gives you
a higher degree of precision.
So you can take all these steps.
But in effect, this is--
as you'll see, this is
the cheapest, the easiest,
and the first one you always do.
You never make a
decision about what
to do until the
process is in the state
of statistical control.
Why is that?
Why am I so adamant about that?
You never go to the next
step until we've done this.
Any of these things
we talked about.
No ideas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] involved
a lot of efforts [INAUDIBLE]
from a an effort point
of view, resources.
[INAUDIBLE] inherent to
the process [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: From an
economic point of view,
you certainly should do it.
It is essentially
almost free, although it
takes a little bit
of someone's effort
and other things like that.
But there's maybe
even a better reason.
AUDIENCE: The process starts
doing something you don't like
and you're going
to do a feedback
system or active control.
You don't really
know why, so you
don't know what your
feedback is going to do.
If it can actually make it
worse because I don't know
the underlying cause anymore.
So it could actually
spiral out of control.
PROFESSOR: This
is really getting
at the heart of the issue.
Richard?
AUDIENCE: Another point
is that you have no chance
to actually get an approximation
of the underlying distribution
when the process [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was
going to be building on Dan
and just saying, it's
understanding the root cause
problem, and you can't really
solve anything or understand
how to improve it until you
understand what's causing
the [? error to ?] be on.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
The whole point with SPC is, if
you remember in this-- in fact,
I barely remember this,
and I made up the slide.
But maybe back in the
first or second lecture,
we had a list of
things that lead up
to good process control.
The first thing was
good housekeeping.
Just have to have
a sensible shop
and don't play around
with the process.
So hold these things consonant.
The next-- so that's
kind of obvious,
but you'd be surprised
how long it took companies
to decide that things like
standard operating procedures
were important.
The next thing
after that is, OK.
Let's take that
one level better,
which is if something's
going wrong with the process
by the definition
that's here, then
that means that
there's something
out there causing the process
to deviate that I could fix.
I could fix it pretty easily.
Bad control over
material variability.
Bad temperature control.
Poor maintenance of the machine.
That sort of thing.
Shouldn't you fix all
those things first
before you go investing in
fancy controls or something
like that?
And sure.
If you're going to then go on
to do process optimization,
it's going to assume
the process is
in a state of
statistical control.
So it's like you're applying
a theory to a situation
that it wasn't meant
to be applied to.
So this is definitely
where you start.
OK.
I didn't mean to be
so preachy today.
I guess it's just the weather.
OK.
Why isn't this going forward?
I have to do this now?
OK.
All right.
So here's an example of a
process being not in control.
And this is maybe more
important than the other one
because this is the kind of
stuff you're trying to detect.
Unfortunately,
when you take data,
you don't get pictures
that look like this.
Because, for example,
at time instance I,
you get one piece of data.
You don't get a distribution.
You get one piece of data.
So this, in effect,
is the challenge
of working with real data.
Now, keep in mind, and this is a
hard thing to keep in mind here
in a classroom, but put yourself
in the position of a production
supervisor or an operator who's
making something and products
come out one at a time.
And as they come out,
you measure them.
And of course, by the
time you've measured it,
the next one is
ready to be measured
and that sort of thing.
So things are
happening pretty fast.
And what you're trying
to decide as you
make those measurements
is, is everything OK?
And you don't have,
with each measurement,
you don't have
enough data to say,
well, here's the distribution.
But we do the best we can.
So here's how it's done.
What you're trying
to do with this
or what this is
basically saying is,
well, look what's
happening here.
In the first two intervals,
things looked OK.
And then what happened here?
Well, obviously, as you
can see from the diagram,
the whole underlying
random behavior
shifted it's mean value.
And it's clear, it also
got greater invariance.
So the underlying
parent distribution,
meaning the underlying random
behavior of the process,
did not stay the same.
It changed at integral 2.
And then down here somewhat
later, it got even worse.
It followed a
bimodal distribution.
So it actually meant
that the probability
of getting a certain
dimension had two peaks.
And the least likely point
was maybe somewhere near--
oh, I guess I've drawn
it the other way.
But yeah.
Well, here's the point.
It's anything but a normal
distribution anymore.
And it's anything but the
original distribution.
So these are some
examples of the process
being not in a state
of statistical control.
Now, the other thing, of course,
that could be happening here--
this is basically saying,
with the exception
of the bimodal thing,
it's basically saying, OK.
You got a normal distribution,
but it's underlying statistics,
the mean and the variance,
are no longer constant.
The other thing
could be happening
is that it's still
random, but it's
switched its
distribution to something
like a uniform distribution.
The real fact of the matter
is that it's probably not
following any
distribution because it's
got a lot of deterministic
behavior underneath it.
But here's the challenge if
you're actually applying SPC.
How do I look at
data in real time
and distinguish the
difference among something
that looks like this?
This is actually a mean shift
here now that I look at it.
Something that looks
like this, which is
exactly what I wanted to see.
Something that looks like this,
where you've got a mean shift.
Something that looks
like this where
I've got a mean shift and
standard deviation shift.
And something like
this, where I just
change the whole
probability distribution.
So how could I look at
individual data points
one by one and decide
what's going on there?
So that's really the challenge.
And when we do come up with
these rules and say, ah,
it's not in control, it's
really because our hypothesis
is that something like
this has happened.
OK.
So back to Shewhart,
and back to practical.
What the Shewhart chart does,
the classic Shewhart chart,
it's an x-bar, and
often, it's done
as an r-chart or a range chart.
I like to use the
s-chart for reasons
I'll get to in just a second.
But what it does is it plots
not the data points themselves.
Not the individual run data,
but a sequential average
of the data.
And I'll show you this
diagram in just a second.
But the basic approach here is
not to take each measurement
and put it on a plot but instead
to take groups of measurements
and plot the average of those.
A simple arithmetic
average of them.
OK?
So if I get a plot, a data
point here, this is actually
the average of a
set of data that
occurred around the interval i.
And the next one here is
the average at i plus 1.
OK?
Why would we do that?
Why not just plot the run
data, meaning the actual data?
Why start off and
say, now, we're
going to look at averages?
AUDIENCE: Because the
evidence or the distribution
of the evidence [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's one very good reason.
You get the narrowing
effect with the sample.
AUDIENCE: Also, you're able
to calculate or estimate
the standard deviation.
PROFESSOR: And
that's exactly right.
So for each of these, I can come
up with a standard deviation
as long as I have enough data.
Each of those.
So each of these is
x-bar sub i is-- well,
let me just do it this way--
is, of course, a sum over
n of some set of data.
And so the other
part of this now
is how many data
points do I take?
OK, that's a really good reason.
There's an even more
fundamental reason
why I would plot this x-bar.
What is x-bar an estimate of?
It's the estimate of the
true theoretical mean.
So, if you will, it's our
estimate of the mean value.
If the process is in a state
of statistical control,
this thing, what is the
true value of the mean?
Or maybe I didn't
state that question
as well as I should have.
How does the true value of
the mean vary over time?
It doesn't.
Exactly.
So what my ideal
for in control is
that if this is the theoretical
mean right here of the process,
then the true mean value
should be a constant.
So what I'm really
plotting here in a sense
are my sample statistics.
Not the data, but my
sample statistics.
And the reason is, in effect,
you have to say, at this level,
I don't care about the data.
What I care about are the
statistics of the data
and what they're telling me
about the underlying behavior.
So that's one of the key
reasons for plotting this.
We're not plotting the data.
We're plotting the
statistics of the data.
There's another reason
that's even maybe--
you'll see some
other reasons why.
But what other
advantage do I get
from calculating the
average instead of--
doing this kind of
averaging instead of just
looking at the raw data?
We already said
it allows us to--
I've said here, it allows
us to be actually plotting
our estimate of the mean.
It allows us to calculate
at each interval
a standard deviation.
What else does it
allow us to do?
Remember, I said
earlier that this is all
based on this being normal.
What's the best way to
guarantee that whatever
it is that I'm looking at is--
whatever variable I'm
actually plotting is following
a normal distribution?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Central limit theorem.
PROFESSOR: Central
limit theorem.
Exactly.
So if you go back
to that, if I'm
doing any sort of
averaging here,
I'm invoking the
central limit theorem.
So even if the underlying
behavior of the process
naturally is not
purely normal, it'll
tend to be normal
when I do the average.
So it's a sort of a
self-fulfilling method
by doing it that way.
OK.
Now, since I can, with
respect to this S chart,
since I can calculate these at
each intervals, you might say,
I could have a
second chart where
I could be plotting sequentially
the standard deviation.
And so I can actually
end up plotting--
let me put that over here.
I can plot my sample
standard deviation.
And I could have
another data point here
and another data point here.
And so I'm actually
looking at both.
I'm plotting the sample
statistics for the mean
and the sample statistics
for the standard deviation.
And again, what should the
underlying standard deviation
be?
It should be a constant.
And these will be samples,
estimates of that.
And they'll be following a
normal distribution as well.
And so again, we'll have to
estimate what that value should
be, but we can get this.
Now, in your text, in most
texts on this, they talk--
I know Montgomery
talks about S charts.
He also talks a
lot about R-charts.
And R-charts basically
just says, for the sample
of end data, what's the range?
The min-max range of it, OK?
Now, range, why do you think
we used range for so many years
as opposed to--
we use R, and a lot of the
literature is on R. Especially
if, let's assume N
is is a number of 5.
I'm taking five samples.
I'm plotting data.
Making decisions on
the factory floor.
Why would I use range
which just involves
a subtraction of a
minimum-maximum number
versus standard deviation, which
is sum of the squares and all
that other stuff?
Why would anybody ever
want to use range?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Um, no.
But I see where you're going.
Yeah, it basically-- you
know, it bounds the data.
But again, what we're
trying to get at
is the underlying
random behavior.
So why would I ever use R?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, think
about the most basic user.
We're talking about
the simplicity of SPC.
You got a pad and
a pencil and paper.
Averaging is pretty easy to do.
Subtracting two numbers
is pretty easy to do.
You write them down.
Doesn't take a calculator.
Doesn't take a computer.
And I know I'm really
starting to sound old now,
but pocket calculators weren't
around for a long time.
And to something that could
take a square or square root,
forget it.
So in the production
floor basis,
you can have a couple
of columns of numbers
and write these things down
and get it very quickly.
Now, the thing is that
this range is actually
a pretty good estimate
of the variance,
and there's some nice stuff
in the text about this
in other books on this.
So range is an estimate of
the sample standard deviation.
So it's not bad in
their correction factors
and all that.
But the reason I like
to do the S is, look.
That's what we do now.
It's easy to take the data.
And very few if
any organizations
are doing it the other way.
So that's what we do.
OK.
Now, a little bit about the
sampling because this is--
such as it is.
That's the theory of SPC. Now,
here's the practice of it.
How do we actually do this?
Well, here it is.
Here's a comb, which
is actually meant
to show you instance in time
or actual production instances.
So each of these vertical lines
is a product, an opportunity
to make a measurement.
That's the real product.
When we do that
sequence then, what
we're saying with this
sequential average, which
is what the Shewhart
approach does,
it says, well, let's take
a group of those, a sample
size N, and we'll call
that sample interval J.
So our time, if you will, is now
when did this set of samples--
when was this set
of samples taken?
And let's do our measurements,
let's do our plotting
based on that.
So for this orange block,
we can calculate, which has,
in this case, six
measurements in it.
So yeah.
So n is 6.
So I can do an average value
for that, for that set of data,
and I can do a standard
deviation for that.
A sample standard
deviation from that.
And then I wait a
certain amount of time.
And I do it again.
And so on.
So for each of these, I get--
do I have one here?
So for each of these, I can get,
of course, an x-bar and an S.
OK?
So you can see there's a trade
off between how many samples I
take and how far
apart I take them.
All right.
First question is--
I'll ask it before somebody does
because somebody always does.
How big does that need to be?
Greater than 1.
You can do it with 2,
especially if you use the range.
But how big does N need to be?
How big should N be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's exactly the
confidence interval issue.
But look at this
relationship here.
Well, yeah.
You remember when we talked
about the mean and then
the invariance of the mean.
And the invariance of
the mean meaning how--
or, sorry, the variance of
the estimate of the mean.
This job.
So if I'm plotting my
estimate of the mean value
and N is a really small
number like 1 or 2,
then I get the maximum
variance of that estimate.
It's going to be
all over the place.
If I increase N, that
gets tighter and tighter.
So I'm getting a better
and better estimate
of what the true mean value is.
So obviously, maximizing
N minimizes the variance
of my estimate of the mean.
And so I'm doing a better
job of estimating the mean.
So why not just make
N a really big number?
Adam.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, it could take you
all day to get a decent sample
size, right?
And something else-- there's a
real issue here that comes up
called time variability.
So within, if you took
a large sample, 50, 100,
the whole day's worth--
you could take a whole
day's worth of production
and say, OK.
That'll give me a great
estimate of the mean, right?
But during that
time, the process
could have been going
all over the place,
changing here and
there, and you just
say, well, let's wait till the
day is over and see how we did.
OK?
So it doesn't give you a
lot of time to intervene.
And again, I can't do
it on the screen here,
but imagine that
I cover this up,
and all you can see-- of course,
you guys can't see anything
now, but all you can see is
what's happening right here.
You don't know what's going
to happen in the future.
And you're trying to estimate
what's going to happen.
If you wait until here to do
that, think of all the product
that you've made and think about
trying to make your next guess.
It really gets
kind of ridiculous.
So there's a trade off.
How big should N be?
Well, big enough to get
a reasonable estimate.
Big enough to be able to detect
changes in a timely manner.
So if I take a lot
of data points,
it's just going to take me
forever to get an estimate.
And then there is the issue
of how far apart they are.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] depend
on the value add of the process
that we're looking at?
Where if you're
adding a lot of value,
you might want to look at it
or more often because it's
costly to miss minor changes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sure.
Sure.
I think at this point, we
look at this in a value--
let's say a value-neutral
fashion, saying, look.
At this point, there is--
your point is well
taken in the following.
There's a cost to every
measurement we make.
average that we take
and all that sort of thing.
In the past, those costs
could be pretty high.
They're tending to be
much lower these days
with automated inspection
and things like that
as a matter of course.
But yes, there's a cost benefit.
So if it's a part where
it's not that important,
you know, so forth and so on.
If you look downstream and
you say it's not a critical--
what's the term I'm thinking of?
It's not a key characteristic
of the product, it can vary,
then maybe this isn't important.
But that actually gets
to the next step, which
is, how critical is a part?
So if I hurry up,
we'll get to that.
But you're exactly right.
So there is a cost of
quality associated with this.
Nowadays, we tend
to think there's
a cost, high cost associated
with not doing this.
OK.
What's the effective-- why
would we actually wait and not
have these boxes right
next to each other?
Sample 6, OK.
So 1 through 6 is the
first sample, 7 to 12
is the next sample, and so on.
Why would I-- why am I
actually showing a gap
between these two?
Why don't I just don't
take any measurements?
Ignore the data.
Why would I ever do that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
Say a little bit
more about that.
AUDIENCE: I guess if there is
certain variation [INAUDIBLE],,
It would be [INAUDIBLE]
any more than other causes
of the variation that we
take in our data samples
right next to each other.
It will have the same cause
of variation affect [? two ?]
of our samples, and in effect,
we [INAUDIBLE] same thing
twice.
So [INAUDIBLE] we will still
have [INAUDIBLE] causes
of variation.
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
I hope you guys heard
that in Singapore.
I couldn't I couldn't
say it any better,
but that's basically it.
And we'll talk about
this I think a little bit
more theoretically later.
But if there is an underlying--
if something happens here
that has some memory,
some history to it,
which causes correlation from
one incident to the next,
you're violating the assumption
of independent random behavior.
If you make this
integral large enough,
there's something actually
called a correlation time.
You can measure
that for a process,
and I think you'll see that
near the end of the term.
If you sample outside
that correlation time,
even though the process
is not truly independent,
it will appear to be
independent, which
is good for what we want to do.
It's sort of like the other
half of using the central limit
theorem.
We get normal,
independent behavior,
even when the individual data
points don't follow that.
There's another reason.
Which is less important today
than it was in the past,
and that is it takes
time to do this.
And you just don't have
time to take all this data.
So you wait.
You grab six, you take
them over to the bench,
and you do whatever
you do with them,
and then you come back as soon
as you can for the next one.
So you have to allow for
this kind of behavior.
Nowadays, again, most production
for anything that's critical
is actually taking the data,
in many cases, on every part.
Every part that's coming out
has some measurement made on it.
I shouldn't say most.
Many.
And this is all available, and
you can choose to use it all.
You can choose to ignore it.
If you think you have
a lot of correlation,
you might ignore it.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It should be.
For these reasons, yeah.
It should be.
Let me go on because I'm doing
exactly what I didn't want
to do, which is talk too much.
So, OK.
I think we know all that.
OK.
So this is what
you would actually
see if you took measurements,
grouped them, in this case,
in groups of N, and
plotted the data.
This is what you would see
if the process were governed
by purely random stationary,
meaning fixed mean invariance,
normal behavior,
because this was
generated, in fact, in
the PowerPoint that's
on the website.
This is-- I think you can
click on this, and the Excel
spreadsheet that
generated it is there.
So you can re-randomize
it and see what happens.
But it's just a
normal distribution.
And this is what you would get
with a normal distribution.
In this case, a random
number generator
that's following
normal distribution.
And you get stuff
that looks like this.
So these are your estimates
of the mean value.
So you can look at
that and say, OK.
Well, you know,
what does it say?
Well, I can observe that--
I can eyeball that the mean
value of the mean value
looks like a constant.
So it looks to me, in
this particular case,
like x-bar is telling
me-- my estimate of x-bar
is that the underlying
meaning is a constant,
and it's probably
about right here.
And likewise, I don't see that
my estimate of the invariance
is telling me that
the invariance is
anything but a constant.
And again, I can look
at its average value.
So this is what you get.
You plot a new data
point, and this
is what you start to expect.
Now, of course, I can look at
this now and get an overall--
a grand mean, which
is an average of all
the average values, and a grand
standard deviation estimate.
I should say a grand average
and a grand standard deviation
estimate.
And say, OK.
Now I know the underlying
distribution of the process.
Once I say that, then I
know what to expect, right?
Now, I can put some lines
on this chart and say,
this is where the data
should fall if everything's
in a state of control.
So this whole idea of
setting chart limits
is extremely important and
often abused and misused.
But here's the idea.
I now have all this data.
And this is before-- this
is just taking raw data
and doing the average on it.
I haven't tried to quantify
this other than that.
Now, I need to start to
put some limits on this
or put some information on.
So the first thing you do,
of course, is say, well,
there's the--
on this set of data, there's
the average in each case.
Now, another thing to
keep in mind-- this
has already happened.
I'm not making any
decisions based
on this about what to do next.
This has already happened.
So the first thing I
need to do, and this
is part of the art of SPC, is
I have to look at that and say,
does it look like it's in a
state of statistical control?
And frankly, at this
point, you eyeball it
and you say, well, you
know, I don't see anything
that makes us look non-random.
And we're going to quantify
that in just a second.
But what else could
I do looking at,
say, a run of data
like this to say, yeah.
It kind of looks like it's in
a state of statistical control.
In other words, if the
process is truly stationary,
if it is truly following
a normal distribution,
what would I expect
this data to look like?
Yeah, it's supposed
to look random.
But how do I look at
it and say, oh, yeah.
That's random.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
If it has a pattern.
If it has a trend.
Things like that.
If it does improbable things.
That's the one that I think--
obviously, a trend.
If it starts to go like this.
If it starts to move up instead
of being flat, that's a trend.
If it goes like
this, that's a trend.
Then those are common trends
that we'll talk about.
There's some ones that are
a little bit more subtle.
Think about
confidence intervals.
OK?
Let's put some confidence
intervals on here.
Let's just put
some lines in here.
And I'll, just for
fun, put three lines
above the average and three
lines below the average.
And I don't even know if
those in the right place.
But remember,
confidence intervals
that said that I
should get 63%--
is that right?
63% in the plus
or minus 1 sigma.
So most of my data
should fall in there.
That one interval.
Even more of it should fall
within the next two intervals
and the plus or minus 3 sigma.
And it's very unlikely that
I'll get very many points
in the 2 to 3 sigma.
A little bit more likely that'll
get them within the 1 to 2
sigma.
So if I look at this
data and I start
to see a lot of data points
up here or down here,
that's pretty unlikely.
That shouldn't be happening.
That's an indication that it's
not following the behavior
that I expected.
Or what if I-- in fact,
I just drew it here.
But what if, in
fact, what I saw--
let me get rid of those lines.
They're distracting.
What if I saw instead
maybe the same data,
but it looked like this instead?
I was getting, I don't know, two
or three data points in a row
all in the same band.
That's pretty unlikely, too.
So based on these things
and actually using things
like confidence
intervals, you can come up
with some rules on this.
I'm going to skip this.
Is covered in the
text very nicely,
but there are ways
of calculating
the sample mean and the
sample standard deviation.
And there's some correction
factors because of biases.
But-- for both the
x-bar and the S-chart.
So what is typically done, and
you always hear about this,
is the plus or
minus 3 sigma limit.
So here's an x-bar chart.
Historical x-bar chart.
I've calculated the grand mean.
Arithmetic average.
I've calculated plus
or minus 3 sigma
of the grand mean with
the correction factors
and all that.
And so what do these
two lines tell me?
These, often called
control limits.
What do those lines mean?
They mean that I expect
99.7% of all the data
to fall within those two lines.
That's all it means.
So a simple SPC
thing and one you
hear about all the time
without much thought,
frankly, is, oh, there's a
data point up there or there's
a data point up there.
Impossible.
Shut down the process.
Everything's wrong.
So you can see that's a good
first order thing to do.
You know, there's only
3 chances in 1,000
that one would be
out there, would
be in one of these two limits.
So that's a pretty
good first cut.
But it's a little bit simplistic
because it is possible
that you'd get a process
that's perfectly in control,
and you'd have one
point that's up here.
It's just not probable,
but it's possible.
So we can do a little
bit better than that.
We can-- and again, we
can do the same thing
with the S-chart.
We can do upper and
lower control limits.
But the more important
thing, I think,
is not waiting for that one
data point that pops up here.
For example, one of the reasons
that might be a problem--
what if I have underlying
behavior that looks like this?
And you can see that
this is, again, this
is truly normal data.
And it's a smaller
sample set that it's
highly improbable I'll get
anything near the 3 sigma
limit.
And this is what
you typically get
if you had a process
that this was in control.
But what if it was doing this?
And you eyeball that.
And would you say, is anything
wrong with this process?
Yeah.
Look, it's trending
up like crazy.
When did that trend begin?
Maybe here.
Now, if all I do is sort
of have an alarm when
I cross over this
upper limit, can you
see that I've been-- something's
been wrong for a long time.
And this could be hours.
It could be milliseconds,
but it could be hours.
Something going wrong
for a long time.
It would be nice to have
something a little bit more
subtle than just simply
waiting for that one
random, potentially just
purely random event.
So-- although we'll talk
about that in just a second.
So one of the things
you can do, as I said,
is look at the data on the
basis of looking at confidence
intervals on the frequency of
getting any sorts of extremes
and trends.
And so there are a number
of different things.
Now, there's a text we
used to use for the class
by DeVore, Chang,
and Sutherland.
We stopped using it
because it's just
got some rough edges and
theoretical problems.
Not problems, but lack of--
it's theoretically
correct, but it's
got some gaps in the theory.
So you need another book anyway.
Montgomery is a little
bit more basic on it.
This is a little bit better
on some of the process
optimization and pragmatic--
these guys are engineers
and less statisticians.
But one of the things
they did is they came up
with the so-called eight rules.
In fact, I'm going to-- let me
go past those for just a second
because--
oops.
OK, never mind.
I was going to talk
about that, but I
don't know if it's in here.
OK.
So the eight rules are based
on really just four tests.
The probability
that the data falls
into one of these
confidence interval bands.
A measure of periodicity.
You should have no
periodicity in the data.
No regularity in it.
Linear trends.
Something that's changing
up or down over time.
And mean shift-- a jump
change in the mean.
All these things
are things are going
to be looking for in the data.
Now, mean, you're
going to hear a lot
about mean shift
throughout the term
because that's your
most-- in some ways,
you can think of that is as
one of the most likely things
to happen.
You're making product with
a certain batch of material,
and you change the batch.
Something changes.
You have a shift change.
You have PM on the machine,
Preventive Maintenance
on the machine.
And the next time you
run it, things jump up.
So the underlying behavior,
something in this model,
just made a step change,
and you saw that out there.
Linear trends, obviously.
Something.
Tool wearing.
Something not-- something
changing over time.
Periodicity.
It could be temperature changes.
It could be something
that's underlying.
That sort of thing.
OK.
So test for out of control.
I think this comes out to eight.
So if you have a set of
data and you look at it,
first thing you
might do is say is
anything outside the plus
or minus 3 sigma limits.
That's really unlikely.
If I get any extreme points
like that, pull the Andon cord.
Stop the production.
Something's wrong.
Let's go out and fix it.
Improbable points.
Now, they've quantified
this by saying, look.
If I get 2 out of 3 points, if
I look at any triad of points,
if 2 or 3 of those are in the
plus or minus 2 sigma band,
that's pretty improbable
based on confidence intervals.
4 out of 5 in the plus or minus,
outside the plus or minus 1
band.
That's pretty improbable.
Or all the data inside
the plus or minus 1 band.
That shouldn't happen, either,
if my process is stationary.
OK?
So each of these
things you can see
could indicate that
it's not following
the expected normal behavior.
Another one is in runs of 8
or more points, am I always--
is there a run of eight points?
That's always above
the mean value.
That's improbable.
It's supposed to be
random on both sides.
Linear trends, of course.
Six points.
And they pick the numbers to
trade off between sensitivity
and resolution.
Six points in a
consistent direction.
Always heading
upwards or downwards.
And bimodal data.
You got points-- if I get points
outside of the central region,
that could indicate-- you go
back to that picture I had.
I have a distribution here.
It's actually following
two different mean values
on either side of
the mean value.
OK.
So how would I apply the
Shewhart charting concept?
OK.
Well, keep in mind, the
first thing I've got to do--
well, let me back up.
Not the first thing.
What I'm trying to
accomplish is this.
I'm in production.
Let's just look at
the x-bar chart.
I'm in production,
and this is now--
I've got some data back here.
This is now-- and I took
another piece of data.
And I want to say, OK.
Is everything all right?
Time to take any action?
I can't do that until I
know I have at least done
my grand mean and I have at
least my upper control limit,
my plus 3 sigma, and
my lower control limit.
So I can't really do SPC
until I have these limits.
Where do they come from?
They came from historical data.
They came from the stuff
that already happened.
So this is a little
bit of a catch-22.
What do you do if the process
is horribly out of control.
And back here, it's
all over the place.
And you just say, oh.
Well, here's the mean value
on the standard deviation.
You can see that these will
be totally bogus limits.
And if it's out of
control back here
and you put those limits
on here, guess what?
It'll appear to be
in control here, too.
It'll stay within these limits.
So it's a bit of a catch-22.
But what do you do with these--
how would I take
these, I don't know,
25 to 50 points before I
actually start doing control?
How would I take
those and say, OK.
Looks good.
What kind of things
would you do if I
were taking data to say, yep.
Looks like I can
now apply the chart.
What am I looking
for in the data?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That could be very
dangerous for a reason I'm
going to show you in a second.
But yeah, you have certain
expectations for the process.
Yeah, absolutely.
But let's say that, again,
here's the historical data.
I've got the historical data.
I always draw it
looking periodic.
So I've got the historical data.
I've got to look at
that data and say,
what do I need to
say about it to say
it's useful for charting?
Number 1, it needs to be normal.
Number 2, it needs
to be stationary.
Then I can start
doing the charting.
What's the test I would
do for it being normal?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Exactly.
You could do things
like-- that's
one of the reasons
we looked at this.
Do a histogram.
What else?
Yeah, yeah.
You do a QQ or normal
distribution plot.
Really good thing to do.
That's pretty fast
and easy to do.
Is it following
normal distribution?
If it's not, we
got a real problem.
I just had a student of mine who
plotted some measurement data,
and he plotted on a QQ,
plot and it was nowhere near
following it.
Didn't make any sense.
And then I found out
that, underlying,
he'd been doing some
very deterministic things
between measurements.
Changing things in a
very deterministic way.
And it came out
exactly in the data.
It should have followed
the normal distribution,
and it didn't because of this.
What else?
Hayden, what else could we do?
AUDIENCE: Well, I'm thinking
you could get the upper
and lower control limits
there in your specification.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: You got to
careful of that, though.
Yeah.
Good point.
That's the same
issue of, you know,
here's what I expect it to be.
But the whole point
about process capability,
which I'm going to get to
in the last five minutes,
is process capability is what
you're dreaming of getting.
This is what you actually get.
And they can do really far off.
The reason I ask you is you
just put that derivation
of the kurtosis up there.
So you could do other
tests on the data
like kurtosis and skewness.
There are all these
different tests
to see if the data is normal.
And then that's
all well and good,
but then you have to look at it.
Is it trending up or down?
Does it have any
of these things?
Before I ever put a
limit on it, can I
say, yeah, that kind
of looks random?
And even without a
limit, you can say, OK.
The data looks like
it's not trending up.
I don't see any
periodicity in the data.
In the case with
my student's data,
there was this big
hump in the data where
it spent a lot of
time doing this,
and then it came back
being [INAUDIBLE]..
It doesn't-- I may be wrong, but
that doesn't look random to me.
OK.
So once I've done that--
and this is where the art is--
then I compute the center
lines and the limits
and I begin plotting
and do this.
And then I start to
apply the eight rules.
Or there are some simpler
rules, often called
the Western Electric rules,
that are actually in your text.
And again, what these rules
mean is these are alarm points.
These mean, to the
best of our ability,
your process is not following
a state of statistical control,
meaning it's not stationary.
There is some sort of
cause on the outside that's
making a change, and it can
be eliminated and identified.
And these are the
Western Electric rules
that are in your text.
Any points outside the limit,
2 to 3 points outside 2 sigma
and 5 points outside 1
sigma, that sort of thing.
OK.
So you can see that just
reviewing what we said,
this is in control.
Here's what the data should
look like if it's in control.
And if you see these types
of behaviors in the data,
it means something
like this has happened.
Mean shift, trends,
bimodal, whatever.
I'm going to skip over this
thing on average run length.
It's very interesting, and
it gives you an issue--
some idea of what to
do about sample sizes.
And it's very carefully
covered in the text.
And you can play with this
beautiful animation that
was made up a long time ago.
And let me just summarize
this by saying, keep in mind,
what we're really doing
here is hypothesis testing.
So all the stuff you just
had on hypothesis testing
is exactly what we're doing.
We're testing the hypothesis
that the data is defined
by a normal distribution.
And these charts are
allowing us to test it,
but it's sort of testing
it as we go along.
And these issues of alpha
and beta probabilities
all fall into this.
So the power of the
test is important.
I think I'm getting
redundant here.
OK.
So again, repeating
what I said earlier,
remodel the process as a normal,
independent, random variable.
By doing sampling
the way we did,
we sort of invoked the
central limit theorem,
and by potentially by
spreading the samples out,
we have a better chance
of it being independent,
even if it's not.
We say, as a result
of it being normal,
there are only two things I need
to know about the distribution.
That's the beautiful thing
about a normal distribution.
Two parameters,
mean and variance.
So it's completely
described by that.
I only need to know
those two things.
So I estimate those with
x bar and S on the data
and then enforce this concept
of stationary conditions.
So if it's a stationary,
normally distributed process,
everything's fine.
If it's not,
everything's not fine.
Oh, yeah.
What happens if it's not right?
This is great.
I read this in the statistics
book a long time ago.
If it's not right,
you call an engineer.
So if you're from a purely
statistical point of view,
you're just saying
something's not right.
OK.
Now, I'm rushing because I
did want to mention this.
I'm sure [INAUDIBLE]
will do some more on it.
But I really wanted to get
to this because of some
of the questions that came up.
This is our empirical
model of the process now.
It's an empirical, statistical
model of the process.
The real world, our
estimate of the real world,
our underlying model, is
this theoretical parent
normal distribution.
That's what you get.
It's not what you want.
It's what you get.
So the question is, how
good is the process?
This is what it is.
Is that good, or
bad, or indifferent?
And that's where you get
into the concept of process
capability.
So we assume the
process is in control.
We assume it follows
that normal distribution.
Then we compare it.
Then we compare it to
things like tolerances.
Where do I want my parts to be?
And there's also this concept
of quality loss, which
is a better way, in
some ways of looking
at design specifications.
The simplest design
specification we can think of
is an upper and lower limit.
A tolerance.
If you can make me a part that
falls between these two limits,
it's a good part.
So can think of that
as a nominal value,
a target, and then an upper
specification limit and a lower
specification limit.
Not control limit, but
Tolerances basically
say, anything in there
is a good part.
Has equal quality, if you will.
Quality loss, which was
introduced by Taguchi
some time ago, basically
said, that's baloney.
And there's some really
good case examples of this,
but that's baloney.
He said, look.
If there's a target value
for some specification,
it's a dimension or a
property of something.
And you can specify that.
That's the best one.
Any deviation from
that is less good,
and there is an actual cost
associated with that deviation.
And he said, not knowing
anything more about it,
we'll call it a quadratic loss.
So the farther you are
from the specified value,
the worse the product is.
And of course, you should always
work your way down this curve.
And there's a way
to calibrate this,
which basically would say--
one way to think of it is--
a simple way to calibrate this.
If I actually have upper and
lower specification limits
here, I can say, what's the
cost of scrapping apart?
And where this curve
crosses that, you say, OK.
That's my calibration constant.
But again, there's some
great case examples
that show that if you
work against quality loss,
you can actually
end up with much--
once you combine together
parts into the whole thing,
you actually end up with a
much better overall quality.
But for the moment, let's
just look at the tolerances.
Process capability in it's
simplest form is just this.
I start with my desired.
I'd like the part to fall
between these two limits.
Once I say that, it doesn't
matter what the target is,
right?
It's just between
the two limits.
I'd like it to fall
between the two limits.
There's my process.
That's the real world.
How did I do?
What's the likelihood
that the part that I make
will fall inside those limits?
That's process capability.
You can, and their numbers--
this is the chart.
You can look at
that and say, OK,
how likely is it that
I make a bad part?
Well, it's the area of that
little space right there.
The way I've drawn this.
It's that area right there,
and it looks like nil here.
So I could look at
that and say, that's.
The probability that
I make a bad part.
Again, to try and give us a
more common basis for this,
things like this
have been defined.
The CP parameter.
Process capability,
which basically says,
what's the ratio of the width of
that window to my plus or minus
3 sigma width?
So is the variability
of my process
similar to or different from
the underlying, the desired?
But it compares ranges only.
And if you look
at this carefully,
that could say that I
could have the following.
I could have a process where
these are my specification
limits.
And here's my distribution.
It's pretty narrow.
So the width of this,
plus or minus 3 sigma,
is well within this width.
So this number would
actually be pretty large.
This window is wide compared
to the window of this.
But how many bad
parts do I make?
They're all bad, right?
So CP is one way of
looking at how well you're
doing with the process.
But it's really only
looking at variability.
So we come up with
this CPK measure,
and there are a whole pile
of these different ways
of looking at stuff.
CPK now penalizes
deviations from the mean.
OK?
So now, this would have
either negative or zero CPK.
And if you do the
calculation, this
is sort of a blend between
how well it's centered in here
and what the deviation is.
So if it's perfectly centered,
then these two numbers--
this is actually-- if it
was perfectly centered
and it exactly fits like
this, what's CPK going to be?
So here's the center
specification and here's x-bar.
This is exactly plus
or minus 3 sigma.
This distance here
will be 3 sigma.
So your process
capability, CPK, will be 1.
So let me just end up
with this and just say
that there are a couple
ways you can look at this.
If I have a process
perfectly centered
and exactly plus or minus
3 sigma limits to my upper
and lower specification limit,
both CP and CPK will be 1.
OK.
If that's the case,
what's my parts
per million, which
many companies will
use to measure their quality?
Once my parts per
million bad parts?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 3 out of 1,000.
So it's a lot.
So yeah.
So CP of 1's not
particularly that good.
Companies like to have it
a lot higher than that.
Here's an interesting one.
Look at the difference
between this.
CP is 1.
CPK is 1.
CP is still 1 because the
width of this distribution
didn't change.
But the mindshift shift was
such that I actually have--
half my parts will now be bad,
and that, if you calculate,
gives you CPK of 0.
Here's another interesting one.
CP went up to 2 because I
narrowed the distribution,
but it wasn't centered.
And so I got a CPK of 1.
This is really good.
This is now plus or minus--
can you see that's plus or
minus 6 sigma out to here?
So what's the likelihood
of making a bad part now?
A couple per million, I think.
this-- I don't have
time to go into it,
but this is sort of the
origin of the 6 sigma
revolution of saying, wow.
If we could do this, we'd
never make a bad part.
There's a little
bit more to that,
but that's process capability.
There are all sorts of
different forms of it.
But the last thing-- let
me just say one more thing
about process capability.
All these things, CP, CPK,
six sigma, they're all great.
Keep in mind that,
again, if you can do it,
if you actually have the data
to do it, it's useful to do,
I think.
What it really says
is here's the design,
and somewhere here
is manufacturing.
And both of these can change.
OK?
Both of these can change.
I can do better manufacturing.
I can center it.
I can do worse manufacturing.
I can buy new equipment.
I can change this all the
ways we've talked about.
I can also go back to design
or start with design and say,
you know, this part really
isn't that important.
This window can
actually be here.
And if I move the
window out there,
look at how the process
capability just changed.
In case 1, the
process capability
of this distribution against
this design is terrible.
The CPK is almost 0.
Now, if I opened up the
window, CPK now skyrockets.
I'm great.
The trend usually is just
the opposite, though.
And this is certainly true in
semiconductor manufacturing is
you might say, here's the
inherent underlying capability
of many of the processes
that we've had historically.
Here were the design
specifications back in 1980.
Line width or
something like this.
Characteristic to mention.
Here they are now.
Oops.
Can't make this product
with this process.
And it was all
because-- so you can
look at how I have to improve
my process capability.
And it's interesting to
talk to people who've
been in the semiconductor
industry their whole lives,
and they'll tell
you this exact story
that, well, we didn't
worry about this back when
the specifications
for this wide.
But all of a sudden, it
became much more important,
so we had to do a lot of
things, including not just SPC,
but some extraordinary things.
OK.
Thanks for your patience.
I ran over, but it was
a technical difficulty
at the beginning.
OK.
Bye bye.